good news from the olympics oh i'd love
to start monday on a good
some with some good news rarely can we
do that but we can hear
um first of all the u.s women's soccer
team
lost to canada so
in dignity on top of indignity not only
do they lose but they lost to canada of
all things
and that means they're no longer in
contention for the gold and that's
that's great news
um also this from the daily wire it says
new zealand transgender weightlifter
laurel hubbard competed and failed
monday
in women's 87 kilogram weightlifting at
the tokyo olympics
so i wish these measurements were an
american damn it or a kilogram i think
what is that uh
the two pounds is a kilogram i could be
totally wrong about that pretend i
didn't say it if i'm wrong
in hubbard's first attempt the
weightlifter tried to lift 120 kilograms
and failed
in the 43 year old second attempt
hubbard lifted a very shaky 125 kilogram
as noted by one of the female
commentators it was very surprising that
the questionable 125 kilogram lift
wasn't challenged with an appeal
on the third attempt hubbard could not
lift the 125 kilogram
bouncing the weight lifter from the
competition
the announcer said quote uh that's the
end of laurel hubbard
as hubbard waved to the cameras and to
those of the competition
uh and so now now uh this
this man is gone and
that's good because he deserves to be
humiliated in this fashion
fashion because this is cheating
i don't care what what the insane
official rules say
you're a male competing against females
you haven't you have undue inherent
biological advantages
you know you have those advantages and
you're using those advantages to your
benefit
and i would say that's cheating
and so so he so he lost but of course
what's happening now
predictably is that the left is saying
that this actually
proves that men don't have an advantage
they're celebrating this too
they say yes see you see there's no then
everybody's worried about laurel hubbard
a man competing against women
and uh and she loses and so you see
there's no
you guys are you're freaking out over
nothing there's no advantage at all
yeah except that this was a 43 year old
pudgy out of shape dude have you seen
pictures of this guy
does not look like a weightlifter at all
looks like i could i could probably beat
him in arm wrestling okay
and um out of shape mediocre athlete
who couldn't come anywhere close to
qualifying against the men
then of course but it's just it's a
coincidence though
couldn't qualify couldn't hack it
against the men and then discovers
late in life that oh actually i'm a
woman well what do you know
that's a coincidence though i mean we
couldn't we could never accuse laurel
hubbard of
having this um revelation for
self-serving reasons even if it was
extremely self-serving it's a
coincidence that it's so self-serving
you understand
but out of completely out of shape
mediocre athlete
um of course he loses
but the fact that he qualified as an
olympic
weightlifter in the first place against
women tells you everything you need to
know
i ask you how many how many pudgy out of
shape
43 year old females are qualifying as
olympic weightlifters
can you give me an example of one
this dude is competing against like 21
year old women
um who have who are you know
talented athletes
against their own competition and he
waltzes in there and it
makes it onto the stage at least
oh but yeah the the fact that this guy
this 43 year old guy couldn't win them
the gold medal proves that men don't
have an advantage
yeah you know what if i if i just uh
stumbled into the olympics myself
and uh you know and was accepted as a
female
and i got onto the track against um
the women in the 100 meter dash
i would lose badly well that
was i guess that proves that men don't
have an advantage or it proves that i'm
just
slow and i have no business being there
and of course i would get beat
if you really want to know about the
advantages there's a website um
called boys versus women.com
boys vs women.com and the whole website
is dedicated
to comparing the world record times the
women's world record um times and track
and field events
against high school boys
and if you go down the list so basically
you have the best high school boy
a child against the best female
athlete in the world and if you go down
the list for all the track and field
world records
the boy wins the boys win every single
one
except for the marathon
all of the others well over a dozen
close to two dozen
um the boys win handily
so so for example 200 meters just
pulling one example at random 200 meters
the woman the women's world record is
21.34
world record best woman female athlete
in the world adult
that was beat by a 14 year old boy with
a 20.89
okay um and that's a pretty significant
difference
by the way the 200 meter dash 1500
meters
uh best female time women's
world record is um is three minutes
50 sec 50.07 and um
that was beat by about two seconds by a
14 year old boy
and you go down the list and you've got
14 year old boys 15 16 17 year old boys
beating the women's world record times
in every single
contest except one
oh but there's there's no advantage no
advantage at all
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated